Do you love watching people climb up buildings
and throw themselves off of them in cool ways?
If you do, these lesser-known parkour
action movies are not to be missed.
Frenchman David Belle, the founding father of
parkour, brought together a group of like-minded,
physically fit people and taught them "la
méthode naturelle" — or natural movement.
Belle saw parkour as a solid way to train,
but some of his friends thought it needed
more flair. This led to the development of
free-running, a parkour offshoot that includes
flips and fancy tricks. These differences of
opinion led Belle to split from the group,
which would become known as the Yamakasi — a
Congolese word meaning "strong in one's person."
In 1998, the Yamakasi got their big break
after catching the imagination of Luc Besson,
who saw their high-flying antics on a TV news
report. The French filmmaker cast them as ninjas
in the film "Taxi 2," then decided to write a
full screenplay based on the team. "Yamakasi"
became the first genuine parkour movie, and its
thrilling action sequences still stand up today.
The movie follows the team as they attempt to
raise money for a sick boy who needs a new heart.
Nine-year-old Jamel suffered a cardiac arrest
after falling from a tree, and a shady surgeon
is trying to rip the boy's mother off. When the
Yamakasi find out, they start hitting the houses
of the hospital's board of directors, hoping
to put enough cash together to save the kid.
Taylor Lautner was a big name in Hollywood when
his New York-set parkour action flick "Tracers"
started shooting in 2013. The former Twilight
star plays Cam, a bike messenger in heaps of
debt with increasingly impatient gangsters. He's
living out of a rented garage and struggling to
keep his head above water when a chance encounter
with high-flying beauty Nikki sends him tumbling
headfirst into a world of crime and free-running.
Nikki is part of a group that uses parkour to
pull off heists around the city, and Cam has
to learn the ropes fast if he wants to join.
"That's the great thing about parkour,
my friend. There are no rules."
Obviously, Lautner had to be
in top shape for the role,
and he ended up doing all his own
stunts. He told Entertainment Weekly —
"It was actually quite surprising to me. I did
extensive training in L.A. with the best people in
parkour, but there were some pretty insane stunts,
and I think they just about let me do everything."
Lautner's physicality and commitment made
for some impressive action sequences,
but the film failed to find an audience. It
didn't come out until 2015, when Twilight-mania
was fading. However, some critics were able to
appreciate "Tracers" for what it is — an often
exhilarating love letter to the Big Apple.
The New York Times wrote in its review —
"[The] film shows love not just for stunts,
but for the dynamic surfaces of the city."
"The Chronicles of Narnia" star William Moseley
leads the line in 2013's "Run," a film about a
teenage parkour enthusiast who gets talked into
becoming a cat burglar by his old man. Petty
crook Mike and his son Daniel travel from city
to city hitting jewelry stores and pawn shops.
They've been avoiding returning to New York
City on account of Daniel's mob boss uncle,
who blames Mike for the death of his
sister — but it looks like they've
run out of other places to go. When they
return, Daniel quickly falls in with the
city's free-running crowd — and he starts
to question his allegiance to his father.
"It's self-expression. Moving through
your environment, freeing your body."
"Run" was a labor of love for writer-director
Simone Bartesaghi, who decided to quit his
managing job and begin working on a movie
about parkour after falling in love with
it. There was some buzz about the script,
and Bartesaghi won the Milan International
Film Festival's Award for Best Screenplay.
So why hasn't anyone heard of the film?
Critics weren't too fond of the other aspects
of "Run" — especially its ending. As
Film Intuition wrote in its review —
"Ignoring the prospect of what might have
been a far better payoff for the subject
matter involving a Parkour contest that’s
mentioned and then immediately discarded,
'Run' instead takes a gangster
B-movie shortcut in its final act."
That doesn't mean "Run" isn't worth your
time, though. The review continued —
"Parkour enthusiasts will still
want to give Run a spin since so
few representations of what they do have
made their way to the silver screen."
David Belle had parted ways with the Yamakasi by
the time Luc Besson wrote the film of the same
name, but Besson would go on to work with
parkour's pioneer in a later project. The
director co-wrote and produced 2004's "District
13," a frenetic French actioner that takes place
in an area of Paris that's been overrun by crime.
It's become so bad that Parisian authorities have
walled the district off from the rest of the
city, leaving the poor inhabitants to fend
for themselves. When a government bomb is
smuggled into the slums, Leito teams up with
undercover cop Damien to find it — uncovering a
sinister plot by the ruling class in the process.
Helmed by Pierre Morel, who would go on to
direct Liam Neeson in "Taken," "District 13"
was well-received in France and the US. While
most acknowledged that the plot wasn't exactly
groundbreaking, the stunning action sequences more
than made up for it. In a glowing review, The New
York Times waxed lyrical about the athleticism
and artistry on show throughout, saying —
"Parkour isn't par-for-the-course movie mayhem,
but a gorgeously choreographed gymnastics of pain
that elevates 'District 13' over the impossible
missions and last stands of the season."
The vast majority of critics agree that "District
13" is worth a watch. This white-knuckle roller
coaster ride holds an impressive 80 percent
rating on Rotten Tomatoes — certified fresh.
The 2009 sequel to "District 13"
brought gravity-defying stars David
Belle and Cyril Raffaelli back together
for another thrill ride through dystopian
Paris. "District 13: Ultimatum" sees our
heroes continue their efforts to bring down
the walls surrounding the slums and rid
the area of drug dealers for good. Now,
there's mass unrest after two police
officers turn up dead in the district,
but Leito and Damien soon discover that it's
a frame job. Corrupt government agents plan to
blow up the five tower blocks at the center of the
district and replace them with luxury apartments.
"Ultimatum" isn't too dissimilar to the first
"District 13" in terms of set-up, but the
action is definitely taken up a notch. While the
original concentrated largely on Belle's parkour,
Luc Besson wanted to make sure to make the most of
Raffaelli's martial arts skills this time around.
Both men pull off multiple physically impressive
feats during the movie's 106-minute runtime,
which flies by in what feels like
an instant. Like its predecessor,
"District 13: Ultimatum" is certified fresh
on Rotten Tomatoes, with a 74 percent rating.
Paris is swapped out for Detroit in 2014's "Brick
Mansions," the American remake of "District
13." Luc Besson and David Belle were once again
involved, but Cyril Raffaelli was replaced by Paul
Walker in what would end up being his penultimate
movie appearance. It was a move Belle approved of:
when one fan complained about the change on
Twitter, Belle defended the decision, tweeting —
"Personally I like very much the work
Paul Walker has done. The film will
be a new experience for me, and I
look forward to working with him."
As is usually the case with Hollywood remakes
of foreign films, "Brick Mansions" didn't live
up to the original. There isn't as much
breathtaking parkour as "District 13" and
Paul Walker doesn't match up to Raffaelli
in terms of combat ability — but there's
an undeniable chemistry between the two
leads. Belle told We Got This Covered —
"When we first met, we sort of looked each
other up and sized each other up. But from
the very first shot, the shells broke, and we
realized that we actually really like each other."
"Got a plan?"
"Kick his ass, don't get squashed."
When Daniel Craig's James Bond chases a nimble
terrorist across the rooftops of Madagascar
in "Casino Royale," that's no ordinary
stuntman he's pursuing. Bombmaker Mollaka
is played by Sebastien Foucan, an old friend
of David Belle and one of parkour's earliest
practitioners. When Belle and Foucan came to
an impasse over the future of their passion,
the latter moved to the United Kingdom and
started calling the activity "free-running"
instead. It was in northern England that
the Frenchman got the chance to showcase his
vision for free-running by co-starring
in the action film "The Tournament."
In writer-director Scott Mann's universe, a
society of rich folks gather the best assassins
in the world for a big shoot-out every seven
years. The killers all descend on a single town,
and the last one standing walks away
with a cool $10 million. Ving Rhames,
Robert Carlyle, and Liam Cunningham all
feature — but when it comes to the action,
it's Foucan who truly impresses. The free-runner's
flowing moves work perfectly with the breakneck
pace of the movie, often distracting
viewers from some of its unfortunate
narrative shortcomings. As Rob Hunter said
in his review for Film School Rejects —
"Sebastien Foucan's leap onto
a moving bus is pretty sweet,
and while I don't pretend to understand
the motivation behind some of his more
extraneous parkour moves, I have to
admit I'm entertained watching them."
"Freerunner" was made on a much lower budget than
most action films, and it definitely shows. Still,
there's no denying that the parkour on display
is outstanding. Lawrence Silverstein's film
follows Ryan as he races across Cleveland with
an explosive collar strapped around his neck.
He's one of eight free-runners selected to
take part in a contest in which the winner
gets $1 million and the losers die. As soon
as one participant crosses the finish line,
the remaining collars detonate. Shady
businessmen watch the action unfold from afar,
placing bets on the outcome. Ridiculous? Maybe.
Worth watching? If you love inventive parkour
and crazy stunts, absolutely. Movie
Mavericks declared in its review —
"'Freerunner' is 'Fast and
Furious' without the cars."
International Freerunning Champion Ryan
Doyle appeared in the film and was also
in charge of choreography, but some of his
work was sadly undone in post-production.
Some shots in "Freerunner" seem like they
end far too early — but the movie is worth
checking out even just for snippets
of the incredibly impressive moves.
"All I know is, after the race
today, something just clicked."
"Yeah, it's called a concussion."
"No, it's a revelation."
"Ong-Bak: The Thai Warrior" introduced
Tony Jaa to the wider world in spectacular
fashion. Mixing the intensity of Bruce
Lee with the acrobatics of Jackie Chan,
Jaa is mesmerizing as humble muay thai
master Ting, who lives in a rural village in
Thailand. When thugs from Bangkok decapitate the
village's prized Buddha statue and steal its head,
Ting decides to follow them — and when he
discovers that the mob has it in their possession,
he throws himself head first into the underworld.
The fight scenes in "Ong-Bak" are gritty and
impeccably choreographed, but watching Jaa
run away from fights is just as entertaining.
In one of the movie's most famous scenes,
Ting goes into full free-runner mode as he's
chased through the narrow lanes of central
Bangkok by over a dozen angry henchmen. The
six-minute sequence goes from impressive to
off the charts as the out-of-towner performs
front flips through narrow panes of glass
and cannonballs through a ring of barbed
wire that no man his size has any right fitting
through. Jaa turns his pursuers into a human
parkour course when cornered, using them
as stepping stones before scaling a wall
and escaping. The critics absolutely loved it
— and if you're an action fan, you will too.